When changing jobs, collect all the information about the new company...
...to find out if the new position offers you growth in terms of finance, pay and technical know-how.
Don't just compare salaries, but find out if there will be pay increases with your current job...
...and what the future salary increments and perks at the new company are going to be.
If they are comparable, then it might be wise to stay put,...
...since you already have job experience, and your present bosses and colleagues...
...know you better than the people at the new company.
It could pay off to gain additional experience and perhaps get into higher-level work...
...than starting from scratch at a new company.
Yet, if there is something new that you will learn at the new company...
...that you can't acquire in your present job, then a change may be worthwhile.
Compare the career prospects at both companies and choose the better.